all right well first of all
thank you okay y'all swagged out too
come on we're just trying to hang in
there okay we're just trying to hang all
right well daniel kaluuya is out here
hunting aliens okay aegis elba lions
you vampires what is in the water with
the brothers i need to know we're trying
to get it we try you know what we're
trying to do we're trying to do
something remarkable like in this movie
jj perry who's from texas yeah when we
first
talked about this crazy idea of cleaning
pools
uh trying to provide for your family but
you hum vampire man let me but when he
showed me the stunts i said oh you got
something now
it's finding the right
person
to
move the movie ahead i said i don't want
to do the movie unless dave franco's in
it and i said i'll tell you why i've
been trying to catch this dude for the
longest i really really admire
and i'm all about his talents and so we
ended up getting lucky and we get with
him and now to watch people watch the
movie and see him completely
killed and destroyed that's that's
that's why we're doing it this is my i'm
bringing them everywhere with my number
one hype man
yeah what was it like on set because it
looked like you guys had a lot of fun i
actually want to know if jamie did any
of his
famous impressions on set
always always yeah which one i want to
know i mean jamie like first off he's
coming in with the greatest energy every
single day no matter what's going on
he's got he's got his backpack that's
also a boombox so he's got the music
coming in his head and he just brings
everyone up it's impossible not to be in
a good mood and to be like that on set
as an actor it just makes you
comfortable comfortable you know you
feel free to take risks and that's when
you do your best work and so again
working with this guy was the easiest
thing i've ever done and he's so
giving as an actor he wants everyone
around him to be good so again he just
he sets the right tone it's a lot of
great people on both sides lots of great
people
i love dave franco i thank you
if you voted for me i love it if he
didn't vote for me i don't like him
excuse me excuse me fake reviews
i love it she's from e.t
she's from et i love it
i've known that for a long time if they
voted for me
next up on canada
oh my gosh well you got cameron diaz to
un-retire maybe she could do the sequel
to this
i mean
remember that role we were talking about
last night
yeah we onto something that's
interesting interesting
interesting one
cameron is just the most incredible
incredible artist
of our time
and for her to
come back and grace us with her artistic
artistic presence it's amazing and the
fact that we got her on the phone with
tom brady uh who taught her how to
un-retire
uh is dope
i love that okay one snoop dogg song to
hunt vampires too you only can pick one
marty was the case
that's you can't top that you can't top
that
[Music]
yeah
was so amazing you see him be completely
different where he's kicking ass and at
the same time he was able to lend us or
allow us to to dig in those crates of
his and murder was the cases was playing
in the back at the beginning of this of
this trailer and our trailer over
performed when it came out it did 19
million views in less than 24 hours so
that that music definitely makes uh
makes it go yeah you got one i can't top
that you kidding me
i would have picked beautiful just cause
it's so ironic
[Music]
yeah yeah i like this the karaoke it
looked very obvious in the film he was
enjoying this character snoop snoop uh i
mean this is this is a different side of
him you know he's an action star now and
we were working with the the best stunt
team in the world you know these are the
the people who taught keanu on the john
wick films and so snoop was right there
in with us and he was doing all the
stunts and like you can see it in the
movie like our director he lets things
play out in these longer shots and you
see snoop he's doing his own stuff you
can't hide that and so it's it's awesome
to see him this way because we've seen
every other side of snoop and it's just
a new thing and i want him to just be
the biggest action star in the world